so explain how many barber shops are
using the software right now and what
you enabled them to do
yeah we've got a little over a thousand
um
barber shops using using the full system
and what we do
is we essentially handle everything that
a barber shop needs to run their
business
from their booking uh to the online
payment
to the point of sale payment in the shop
and then all the back-end stuff
paying out the barbers crm marketing
it's really a full end-to-end system
focused specifically on the vertical
barber shops we like to think of
ourselves as providing everything that
they need to run their business so they
don't have to look outside of squire
for anything how much do you charge them
for this how do you charge them for this
and how did you come to that
yeah so these are these are small
business owners um
and we felt early on that small business
owners
were pretty sensitive to their overhead
and there's
limit on how much you can charge them uh
so we we charge a sas fee starting at
100 a month
um up to going up to 250 a month and
that that's really the upper limit of
what
uh what we charge the shops directly so
they can easily afford to pay that
hundred because
you're going to get them an incremental
customer or two a month and then they
break even is that about right
yeah it's not how they look at the
decision yeah we don't really lean
with lead with we're going to send you
new customers although we do send some
new customers we
really focus more on we're going to make
your life easier and
running your shop easier we're going to
streamline all of your operations
we're going to take things that used to
take you four or five hours a week and
now it's just literally flipping a
button turning on
one feature and it handles it all for
you
barber shops are actually collections of
a bunch of little businesses
i believe in most cases like hair salons
where each of the barbers is
running their own little 1099 business
correct so if i own a barber shop and i
have
four or five people cutting or four or
five chairs they each are basically i'm
either renting those chairs out or
revenue sharing is that correct yeah
exactly see
usually you see the renting which we
call the booth rental model
or it is a revenue share which is called
the commission
model in the industry so it's usually
one of those or a hybrid of the two
and you're right the overwhelming
majority of barbers are 1099s
even though if they're on the commission
model they're treated more similarly to
employees in the sense that they have a
schedule and you know they have to
kind of do what the owner says and if
they're booth rental then it's really
they just do their own thing they come
and go as they please
what do they charge for a booth rental
you know a barber shop in a
in a major city la atlanta new york yeah
two to three hundred to three hundred a
week usually
okay so they pay a thousand dollars a
month
fifty bucks a day but they get a hundred
percent of the revenue that comes in
then
exactly yeah uh so if you had five
if you had six chairs in your barber
shop and you had them fully rented
barbershops making six thousand on the
chairs they're paying
two thousand dollar two or three
thousand dollars to keep the store up
and running they make the other three
thousand clear
yeah is the basic concept for running it
like a co-working space
uh we've this has got to be extremely
complicated then
in terms of billing and separating it so
that's what your software does is you
say hey these three chairs are being
rented
and then i'm assuming some people do a
hybrid right and they rent three chairs
and then three chairs they're doing on
commission
yeah it gets surprisingly complicated
really quickly
more so than what most people would
think um but yeah you're right
depending on how the shop is set up um
the
owner has to if it's a booth rental he's
got to
be on he or she has to be on top of uh
collecting his money
you know every week so that in itself
you know it is a task
um and then a lot of shops want to have
a centralized point of sale system
so now you know how how do you divvy
that up you know how do you make sure
that each barber gets
uh paid what they're owed and the
shopkins with their old and then you
have to think about
routing tips it can get very very
complicated and that's what we saw for
all of those pain points
with software